but here in vegas it is all about fat
tuesday on fremont
and rocky is live at a new local
restaurant where you can celebrate
safely
and deliciously look at you hey rocky
looking good
hey you guys yeah thank you you know
i've gotten used to reporting in a mask
but now on mardi gras it's
reporting in two mess because look at
these outfits you gotta get into the
spirit okay so first and foremost for
mardi gras
we're making cocktails right lisa yes we
are okay so what do we have what's it
called and why is it significant for
today well the
king mardi gras and it's kind of like a
mix between a french 75
and a king's cup cocktail well let's get
into it what do we put into this drink
let me help you
you have a little bit of tropical
infused tequila boom
throw that right in there there we go
and then we have a little bit of
demerara
sugar okay yeah boom ooh
look at that yeah and a little bit of
fresh lemon
perfect now why is this the drink of
mardi gras well it's a little bit of um
it represents new orleans and mardi gras
so it's french 75 and the king's cup
which is also
a mardi gras cocktail so okay so while
you shake that up i'm going to talk to
the owner
the founder of vegas test kitchen a
brand new restaurant here on fremont
street
jolene why are you celebrating mardi
gras here well lots of reasons but one
i'm from new orleans so
and i have not been home in quite some
time like a lot of us have not been able
to travel
so we wanted to bring that spirit of new
orleans to las vegas yes
yes you know funny thing you guys
brought the new orleans weather here too
because the wind
actually knocked down the alleyway that
you guys had decorated
we did it was absolutely gorgeous in the
alley and the winds
came and uh just kind of swept it away
that's right because we brought the
party inside what are you expecting here
tonight
uh we're gonna have some live jazz we
have amazing food we have amazing
cocktails
you're definitely gonna feel like you're
in new orleans and it's bad tuesday
i cannot wait i'm already feeling like
we're in here once i get a taste of this
drink okay it's ready
so okay before we get to the drink kind
of introduce people to the concept of
vegas test kitchen because it's so
unique i love it here absolutely so we
are
a like multi-concept restaurant so
there's seven different
concepts within one space okay so
everything from bagels and pizza
to bun meats and banishka and sushi
so you can literally order from all
these amazing chefs in one transaction
i love that yeah when we're not doing
that we're throwing parties like this a
lot of pop-up
events so we're supporting local
restaurants local chefs so
i think lisa from main street provisions
it's time
to support your work how about that
enjoy cheers
cheers cheers happy mardi gras
we'll get into the food next yeah slow
down on
those uh drinks there you got to come
back and during the 4 pm newscaster
rocky
that'll make the report better that's
true i know you're already doing great
thank you so much rocky